as if there isn't already a good enough
case of obstruction of justice against
Donald Trump NBC News has now learned
the Donald Trump is talking to his
friends about asking the Attorney
General Jeff Sessions to prosecute
Robert Muller the special prosecutor
who's carrying out the Trump Russia
investigation that we've been talking
about since the firing of James Comey as
FBI director shortly thereafter he was
appointed and nbcnews.com Howard Fineman
is quoting an unnamed Trump advisor who
said here's how it would work we're
sorry mr. Muller you won't be able to
run the federal grand jury today because
he has to go to testify to another
federal grand jury presumably one where
he would be a target which is also weird
because usually people don't testify
before grand juries when they are the
ones suspected of crimes but I guess who
cares about the details when it's all
nonsense right so the real big question
is you charge Robert Muller what would
the charges actually be and we have no
idea and this is apparently an
alternative way that Donald Trump is
thinking of to get rid of Robert Muller
short of straight-up firing him and
according to a friend of trumps Trump
does realize that if he fired Muller the
firestorm would be such a train wreck
that it could end up helping Muller or
at least hurting Trump in the long run
so apparently this is an alternative as
if this wouldn't also create a firestorm
right and it is riveting to watch how
Muller who used to be sort of like the
darling of the right is now being
smeared every which way by the committed
Trumpets and many Republicans remember
that Obama decided to keep Muller as FBI
director when he became president
because he believed that he was able to
put political party aside molars a
Republican in case you didn't know and
determined that Robert Muller is a good
person to lead the FBI because he has
integrity and he has intelligence and he
has a commitment to the job that goes
beyond partisanship and at the time
Republicans loved it they've always
loved Robert Muller until now
and as ludicrous as the idea of
prosecuting robert muller is i know for
sure pat that i'm gonna get emails from
the committed Trumpets who listen to the
show and watch the show and they're
gonna say good for Trump because Muller
deserves to be prosecuted for the
witch-hunt he's carrying out which of
course doesn't tell us what the crime is
that you would prosecute robert muller
for you really can't fire robert muller
no the optics of it would be absolute
disaster Trump even seems to get even
Lindsey Graham said that if Trump was to
fire Muller would be the end of his
presidency you think back to Watergate
Republicans were with Nixon until he
decided to fire the special prosecutor
Archibald Cox and I turned on him and
who do you remember who else was also
fired by Nixon in that entire theater
was talked about the deputy being fired
and he had to resign here in the
Ripper's that yeah that's right yes so
I'm ready I mean you know go ahead send
me the emails I know the committed
trumpets are gonna say good good for
Trump for taking a stand and getting rid
of this guy but they're unable to
explain even their simplest political
positions in a coherent way there's no
foundation on which to base their views
but they will be completely and totally
sure that it's correct to prosecute
robert muller somehow yeah I don't deny
that this account happened but is it
possible that he was just being
facetious I mean if he's in a room with
his friends yeah the guy we know will
say anything but he's able if
sarcastically would is Trump capable of
actual sarcastic or satirical comments I
don't know yeah it's not it's not clear
to me that he is and small little detail
in the back of this the idea is Trump is
thinking of telling Jeff Sessions to
prosecute robert muller didn't Jeff
Sessions recuse himself on anything
related to Russia like what why would
Trump go to sessions to have him fire
Moeller if he's recused if you're
recused on Russia then firing the next
guy investigating Russia after James
Comey was already fired to get him away
from the Russia story that's sort of
being involved with Russia stuff which
supposedly Jeff Sessions isn't supposed
to be yeah you got to go to the Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein sure
yeah great great person as a number two
de to put pressure on this is not the
way an innocent person behaves right I
heard an
sort of devil's advocate which was
listened David here's what you don't
understand Trump is so delusional that
he may genuinely believe that there's
just nothing to investigate and that the
entire investigation is a waste of time
if your Trump and you truly deeply
believe that and you believe that you're
innocent you might do everything Trump
has been doing to stop the investigation
not because you think you're guilty and
they're gonna find something but merely
because you believe it's a waste of time
and you just want to get them to not not
waste time this way but outside of that
very difficult to believe hypothesis and
and I know that we say Trump does seem
to have personality disorders that would
be indicative of a pretty serious
disconnect from the real world but this
is not how an innocent person behaves it
is not what an innocent person would do
period the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership